Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. 23 year old Paul Unions arrived in Australia from his hometown of Birmingham, England on December 22, 1989. Like many international backpackers before him, Paul had heard great things about the land down under and was looking forward to a summer of travel and adventure before embarking on a six month working holiday. He spent the first six weeks of his trip staying
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。关于保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本期节目备注。1989年12月22日，23岁的保罗·尤宁斯（Paul Onions）从他的家乡英国伯明翰抵达澳大利亚。和许多前来的国际背包客一样，保罗听闻了这片南半球大陆的美好，并满心期待在开启为期六个月的工作假期之前，度过一个充满旅行与冒险的夏天。他将行程的前六周花在了
at a hostel in Sydney where he visited the sites of the city and hung out with fellow travellers before deciding to head south to Victoria to see if he could find a job fruit picking. Paul considered catching a bus for the near 1,000 kilometre journey but several other backpackers advised him that hitch hiking was easier and a great way to save money. They recommended he take the triad and test the route, catch a train to Liverpool in Sydney's south west, walk to the Hume Highway then hitch a ride south to Melbourne. Following this advice, on January 25, 1990 Paul Unions boarded the train to Liverpool arriving at approximately 1pm. He set off for the Hume Highway on foot carrying all of his possessions
悉尼的一家旅舍里，在那里他游览了城市的景点，并与同行的旅行者们结伴闲逛，随后决定向南前往维多利亚州，看看能否找到一份采摘水果的工作。保罗考虑乘坐巴士完成这近1000公里的旅程，但其他几位背包客建议他，搭便车不仅更容易，而且是省钱的好办法。他们向他推荐了一条屡试不爽的路线：搭乘火车前往悉尼西南部的利物浦（Liverpool），步行至休姆公路（Hume Highway），然后搭便车向南前往墨尔本。听从了这一建议后，1990年1月25日，保罗·尤宁斯登上了开往利物浦的火车，并于下午1点左右抵达。他背着所有的随身物品，步行出发前往休姆公路。
in an old green coloured army rucksack. Although traffic was busy, Paul wasn't having any luck hailing a ride and after an hour of wandering along in the oppressive afternoon sun, he veered off the highway at the town of Kassoula to refresh with a drink and a chocolate bar. Lost resting at Lombardo's news agency, Paul was approached by a stocky tanned skin man with dark hair and light eyes. He had a bushy horseshoe shaped mustache that Paul likened to famous Australian cricket player, Merv Hughes. The man introduced himself as Bill and asked the British backpacker if he needed a lift, offering to drive him as far as Canberra, a 280 kilometre drive south. Paul gratefully accepted the ride.
物品装在一个旧绿色的军用帆布背包里。尽管交通繁忙，但保罗并没有运气招到一辆便车。在令人窒息的午后阳光下游荡了一个小时后，他在卡苏拉（Kassoula）小镇偏离了公路，准备去买一杯饮料和一块巧克力棒来提提神。保罗在伦巴多（Lombardo）报社休息时，一个身材敦实、皮肤晒黑、留着深色头发和浅色眼睛的男子走了过来。他留着浓密的马蹄形胡须，保罗觉得这很像著名的澳大利亚板球运动员默夫·休斯（Merv Hughes）。这名男子自我介绍叫比尔，并问这位英国背包客是否需要搭便车，主动提出开车送他到坎培拉，这是一段向南280公里的车程。保罗感激地接受了搭车的好意。
The two men climbed into Bill's Silver Nissan Patrol four-wheel drive vehicle, which had a red stripe down the side, chrome-plated side steps, a bull bar, curtains on the rear door windows, and a lamb's wool seat covers. Bill threw Paul's rucksack onto the back seat before getting behind the wheel and heading south along the Hume Highway. The pair engaged in small talk about the hot weather and Paul's upcoming travel plans. Bill was friendly and easy to talk to, explaining his family was from Yugoslavia and that he lived locally where he worked for the Roads and Traffic Authority in Liverpool. He was recently divorced and currently on a break from work, taking the opportunity to head to Canberra for a holiday with friends.
两个男人坐进了比尔的银色日产途乐（Nissan Patrol）四轮驱动越野车。车身侧面有一条红色的条纹，配有镀铬侧踏板、防撞杠、后门车窗上的窗帘，以及羊毛座椅套。比尔将保罗的背包扔到了后座上，然后坐到方向盘后面，沿着休姆公路向南驶去。两人闲聊着炎热的天气和保罗接下来的旅行计划。比尔很友好，也很好沟通，他解释说他的家人来自南斯拉夫，他在当地生活，并在利物浦的道路交通管理局（Roads and Traffic Authority）工作。他最近刚离婚，目前正处于休假状态，借此机会和朋友们一起去堪培拉度假。
Paul politely responded to Bill's questions, advising that he had no family in Australia and that up until recently he had been in the British Navy. Bill asked Paul if he had any special forces training in the military to which he responded no. He worked as an air conditioning engineer. Bill's demeanor then started to shift, a conversation about immigration ensued during which Bill started to get agitated as he made several anti-British and anti-Asian remarks. The pair drove onwards in silence, Paul taking the moment to study his tense driver, noticing how Bill kept eyeing the rearview mirror and would gradually slow the car down before speeding up again as though contemplating whether or not to stop. Bill then explained that at this point
保罗礼貌地回答了比尔的问题，告知对方自己在澳大利亚没有家人，而且直到最近他还在英国海军服役。比尔问保罗在军队里是否受过任何特种部队训练，保罗回答没有，他曾是一名空调工程师。比尔的神情随后开始发生变化，随后他们聊到了移民话题，期间比尔开始变得激动，并发表了几番反英和反亚裔的言论。两人在一片沉默中继续开车，保罗趁机观察着这位神情紧张的司机，注意到比尔不断地看着后视镜，并且逐渐把车速减慢，随后又加速，似乎在犹豫要不要停车。接着，比尔解释说，在公路的这个路段，
on the highway the radio signal started to fade and he would need to pull over shortly to grab some cassette tapes to listen to instead. Paul noted this as odd as there was already a number of cassette tapes within easy reach between the driver and passenger seats. As they came to a rise in the road about one kilometre from the entrance to Belangelo State Forest, Bill pulled the car over and started rummaging around under the driver's seat, saying he was looking for some tapes. Paul emerged from the vehicle to stretch his legs, an act that immediately drew Bill's eye, who warded his passenger to get back in. Paul did as he was told and fastened his seatbelt. Bill rummaged under the driver's seat once more
广播信号开始减弱，他不久后得靠边停车去拿几盘磁带放来听。保罗觉得这很奇怪，因为驾驶座和乘客座之间明明已经放了许多触手可及的磁带。当车子开到一个距离贝兰格洛州立森林（Belangelo State Forest）入口约一公里处的上坡路时，比尔把车停在路边，开始在驾驶座底下翻找起来，说他在找几盘磁带。保罗下车活动了一下筋骨，这个举动立刻吸引了比尔的目光，他警告乘客坐回车里。保罗照做了，并系好安全带。比尔再次在驾驶座底下翻找
before lifting out a revolver and pointing at Paul's face, saying this is a robbery. Paul cited the shiny copper ends of at least four bullets in the handgun cylinder, confirming the weapon was loaded. He sat in complete disbelief, wondering if Bill was just having a laugh at his expense. After all, he was a backpacker travelling on a tight budget with nothing of value. He had nothing to steal. Yet, the menacing look in Bill's eyes assured him this was no joke. Paul slowly started unbuckling his seatbelt, causing Bill to bark. Put that fucking seatbelt back on. When Bill pulled out a bag full of ropes, Paul knew he had to escape the situation immediately. The bag of ropes seemed far more
接着拿出一把左轮手枪，对准保罗的脸，说这是一场抢劫。保罗注意到手枪弹巢里至少有四颗子弹发亮的铜质弹头，确认这把武器是上膛的。他完全不敢相信眼前的一切，心想比尔是不是只是在拿他开玩笑。毕竟，他只是一个预算紧巴巴、身上没有任何值钱东西的背包客。他根本没有什么可偷的。然而，比尔眼中那股充满威胁的眼神向他保证，这绝不是开玩笑。保罗慢慢开始解开安全带，这引得比尔大吼道：“把那该死的安全带重新系上。”当比尔掏出一袋绳子时，保罗知道自己必须立刻逃离这种境地。那袋绳子在他看来，
sinister to him than the gun did. In a split second decision, he unclipped his seatbelt and leapt from the car, racing northwards up the Hume Highway. Bill yelled out, stop or I'll shoot, before firing at Paul. The bullets missed as the backpacker started running in a zigzag motion to make himself a harder target to hit. Paul onions, quote. I started running across the roadway and three or four cars were off to miss me, but nobody would stop. I looked up and didn't see any cars coming, and I turned around for the first time, and there was Bill chasing me. He was yelling at me, get back in the car, get back in the car. The two men reached the grassy median strip in the center of the highway,
比那支枪还要阴森恐怖。在电光石火的瞬间，他解开安全带，从车上跳了下去，沿着休姆公路向北狂奔。比尔大喊着“站住，否则我开枪了”，随后向保罗开枪。子弹打偏了，因为背包客开始以之字形路线奔跑，以增加被击中的难度。保罗·尤宁斯回忆道：“我开始横穿马路，有三四辆车堪堪避开了我，但没有人停下来。我抬头看去，没有看到有车驶来，我生平第一次回过头，发现比尔正在追我。他朝我大喊：‘回到车里去，回到车里去。’”两人跑到了公路中央长满草的隔离带上，
where Bill launched a paw, grabbing him by the right sleeve of his shirt. The fabric tore, giving Paul one last chance to escape. He ran towards oncoming traffic whilst frantically waving his arms in the air as the Tarago van with a female driver approached. Paul stood directly in its way, deciding he would rather be run over than face whatever Bill had in store for him. When the van came to an abrupt stop, Paul ran to the passenger side sliding door, pulled it open, and jumped inside. He locked the door behind him while yelling at the confused driver. He's got a gun. He's got a gun. The driver of the Tarago, Joann Berry, sped away and took Paul straight to Bowerill police station,
比尔在那里伸出一只手，抓住了他衬衫的右袖。布料撕裂了，这给了保罗最后一次逃生的机会。他一边在空中疯狂挥舞着手臂，一边朝着迎面而来的车流跑去，此时一辆由女司机驾驶的塔拉戈（Tarago）厢式车正驶来。保罗径直站在车前，决定哪怕被车撞倒，也绝不面对比尔可能对他的图谋。当厢式车猛地停下时，保罗跑向副驾驶侧的滑动车门，拉开车门跳了进去。他反锁好车门，朝着惊恐万状的司机大喊：“他有枪！他有枪！”塔拉戈的司机乔安·贝里（Jo-Ann Berry）一脚油门加速驶离，直接将保罗送到了鲍拉尔（Bowerill）警察局，
where he reported his near-death confrontation with Bill. He explained that his rucksack was in Bill's car containing all of his belongings, including clothing, a camera, a plane ticket, $500 cash, his British passport, a gold chain, and some personal papers. A message was broadcast over police radio notifying officers to be on the lookout for a silver Nissan Patrol four-wheel drive vehicle being driven by a man with a Murph Hughes-style mustache. Given that Paul was unable to take note of the vehicle's number plate, he was advised that the chances of locating his assailant would be slim. Before Paul left the police station, a senior officer pulled him aside to tell him how lucky he
他在那里报告了自己与比尔险死还生的对峙经过。他解释说，他的背包还在比尔的车里，里面装着他所有的随身物品，包括衣物、一台相机、一张机票、500澳元现金、他的英国护照、一条金项链以及一些个人文件。一条消息通过警方电台播报出去，通知各警员注意搜寻一辆银色日产途乐四轮驱动越野车，驾驶员留着默夫·休斯（Merv Hughes）式的胡须。由于保罗没能记下车牌号，警方告知他找到袭击者的几率微乎其微。在保罗离开警察局之前，一位高级警官把他拉到一旁，告诉他自己能活下来是多么幸运，
was to be alive, hoping the experience provided the foreign backpacker a valuable lesson on the dangers of hitchhiking. Paul was handed money for a train trip back to Sydney, where he returned to his former hostel and warned other travelers of his ordeal. Paul remained in Australia for several months before returning to England, vowing to never hitchhike again. Four years later, the unsolved murders of James Gibson, Deborah Everest, Simone Schmidel, Gabor Neugebauer, Anja Habschied, Joanne Walters, and Caroline Clark received heavy coverage by international media outlets. They titled the killer The Beast of the Bush as UK tabloids published unsubstantiated claims that the perpetrator had murdered 20 people across two decades.
希望这段经历能给这位外国背包客关于搭便车危险性的宝贵一课。保罗拿到了一笔用于乘坐火车返回悉尼的钱，他回到了曾经住过的旅舍，并向其他旅客警告了自己的遭遇。保罗在澳大利亚逗留了几个月后返回英国，并发誓再也不搭便车了。四年后，詹姆斯·吉布森（James Gibson）、黛博拉·埃弗雷斯特（Deborah Everest）、西蒙妮·施米德尔（Simone Schmidel）、加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔（Gabor Neugebauer）、安雅·哈布席德（Anja Habschied）、乔安妮·沃尔特斯（Joanne Walters）和卡罗琳·克拉克（Caroline Clark）这几起未破的谋杀案受到了国际媒体的大肆报道。他们将凶手冠以“丛林野兽”（The Beast of the Bush）的称号，英国小报则发表了未经证实的报道，称凶手在二十年间杀害了20人。
One crude headline read, Crocodile Dundee Adventure Girls Found Dead in the Woods, whilst Australia Phobic Articles declared, 250,000 people a year tracked to danger. As a direct result of the murders, Australia was ranked by foreign media as one of the five most dangerous locations for tourists to accept a ride from strangers, listed alongside South Africa, Chile, Zimbabwe, and the United States. Meanwhile, the Balingalo area had reached instant notoriety, prompting visitors to venture into the forest to satisfy their morbid curiosity. Balingalo signs along the Hume Highway were stolen on two separate occasions by visitors seeking a macabre souvenir. As Englishman Paul Unions read news reports of the seven
其中一个耸人听闻的大标题写道：“《鳄鱼邓迪》式的冒险女孩在树林中被发现死亡”，而恐澳文章则宣称：“每年有25万人在追踪中陷入危险”。作为这些谋杀案的直接后果，澳大利亚被外国媒体列为游客接受陌生人搭车最危险的五个地方之一，与南非、智利、津巴布韦和美国并列。与此同时，贝兰格洛（Balingalo）地区瞬间臭名昭著，促使游客们冒险进入森林，以满足他们病态的好奇心。休姆公路沿线的贝兰格洛路标曾两次被企图寻找恐怖纪念品的游客盗走。当英国人保罗·尤宁斯读到关于在澳大利亚发现的七名
backpackers found murdered in Australia, he felt a shiver run up his spine. He immediately recognised the similarities between the crimes and his encounter with Bill on the Hume Highway in January 1990. Paul picked up the phone and contacted Australian authorities, realising he may have survived a brush with the Balingalo serial killer. Paul Unions' harrowing escape was corroborated by his rescuer Jo-Ann Berry, who had independently reported the incident via the Task Force Air hotline. The formal statement the British backpacker provided Bowerl police immediately following the attack had been misplaced over the years. However, one officer who had been on duty that day still
遇害背包客的新闻报道时，他感到脊背发凉。他立刻认出了这些罪行与他本人在1990年1月在休姆公路上遭遇比尔的事件之间的相似之处。保罗拿起电话联系了澳大利亚当局，意识到自己可能从与贝兰格洛连环杀手的擦肩而过中幸存了下来。保罗·尤宁斯惊心动魄的逃生经历得到了他的救命恩人乔安妮·贝里（Jo-Ann Berry）的证实，后者曾通过“空中特遣队”（Task Force Air）热线独立报告了这起事件。这位英国背包客在袭击发生后立即向鲍拉尔警方提供的正式口供在岁月的流逝中被搞丢了。然而，当年值班的一名警官依然
had a notebook that contained some details she had jotted down about the incident, including that the perpetrator had a distinct horseshoe mustache in the same style as Australian cricket player Merve Hughes, drove a silver four-wheel drive, was of Yugoslavian descent, and claimed to have worked at the Roads and Traffic Authority. Four and a half months after the last of the seven young backpackers who were uncovered in Balingalo, her shared memorial service was held in the forest at the former side of the police command post. February 5, 1994 was a scorching hot day, but despite the heat, over 200 mourners gathered to pay their respects to the victims and to their loved ones, with relatives, friends, locals, and officials in attendance.
保留着一个记事本，里面记录了她当时随手记下的关于这起事件的一些细节，包括袭击者留着与澳大利亚板球运动员默夫·休斯（Merve Hughes）同款的标志性马蹄形胡须，开着一辆银色四轮驱动车，是南斯拉夫血统，并声称曾在道路交通管理局工作过。在贝兰格洛被发掘出的七名年轻背包客中的最后一人的尸体被找到四个半月后，他们在警察指挥所原址的森林里举行了一场联合追悼会。1994年2月5日是一个酷热难耐的日子，但尽管天气炎热，仍有200多名悼念者聚集在一起，向受害者及其亲人表达敬意，亲属、朋友、当地居民和官员均有出席。
For Anglican Reverend Steve Davis, the service aimed to help the community and families come to terms with the tragedy, closing one chapter while ensuring the case remained in the spotlight until it was solved. Reverend Davis explained, The service talks about injustice in our world and the fact, as it were, that the good guys seem to often get it, but the bad guys get away with it. Where is the justice? That's the question I'll be asking with the families today. New South Wales Premier John Fay acknowledged the tireless efforts of the New South Wales police force and state emergency services before unveiling a memorial plaque honoring the victims.
对于英国国教牧师史蒂夫·戴维斯（Steve Davis）而言，这场追悼会的目的是帮助社区和家属正视这场悲剧，画上一个句号，同时确保该案件在水落石出之前持续受到关注。戴维斯牧师解释道：“追悼会谈到了我们世界中的不公，以及好人往往受害而坏人却逍遥法外的现实。正义在哪里？这就是我主要和今天的家属们共同探讨的问题。”新南威尔士州州长约翰·费伊（John Fay）对新南威尔士州警察部队和州紧急服务部门的不懈努力表示肯定，随后为纪念受害者的纪念匾揭幕。
At red, this plaque commemorates the memory of the following persons whose remains were found in the Balingalo Forest during 1992 and 1993. Caroline Jane Clark, United Kingdom Deborah Phyllis Everest, Australia James Harold Gibson, Australia Anja Habschied, Germany Gabor Kurt Neugebauer, Germany Simone Loretta Schmidl, Germany Joanne Leslie Walters, United Kingdom Nothing can separate us from the love of God in Christ the Jesus, our Lord. Reeths were laid alongside the plaque, as James Gibson's mother Peg thanked those present for their prayers and support, saying, As a mother of one of the young people buried here in the forest,
上面写着：“此纪念匾旨在缅怀以下人员，他们的遗体于1992年和1993年期间在贝兰格洛森林被发现。卡罗琳·杰恩·克拉克，英国。黛博拉·菲利斯·埃弗雷斯特，澳大利亚。詹姆斯·哈罗德·吉布森，澳大利亚。安雅·哈布席德，德国。加博尔·库尔特·诺伊盖鲍尔，德国。西蒙妮·洛雷塔·施米德尔，德国。乔安妮·莱斯利·沃尔特斯，英国。没有什么能让我们与我们在主基督耶稣里神的爱隔绝。”花圈被摆放在纪念匾旁，詹姆斯·吉布森的母亲佩格（Peg）感谢在场人员的祈祷与支持，她说道：“作为埋葬在这里森林里的其中一位年轻人的母亲，
I feel I can talk for my own family, but also, I feel whatever I say will be echoed by the other families involved. Premier Fay said police would not stop hunting for the killer. Remarking, this is a crime which the New South Wales police would dearly love to solve and I'm sure the entire New South Wales community would want to know that someone has been brought to justice. To assist investigators with identifying a suspect, several criminal experts were called in to create a psychological profile of the Balingalo serial killer. The first was assembled by forensic psychiatrist Dr. Rod Milton, who had visited each crime scene upon their discovery. He concluded the murders followed a similar pattern and were premeditated by someone of sound
我觉得我可以代表我们自己的家庭发声，同时我也觉得无论我说什么，都会引起其他涉事家庭的共鸣。”费伊州长表示，警方绝不会停止对凶手的搜捕。他评论道：“这是一起新南威尔士州警方极其渴望破获的罪行，我也确信整个新南威尔士州社区都希望得知有人已被绳之以法。”为了协助调查人员识别嫌疑人，几位犯罪专家应邀前来，为贝兰格洛连环杀手绘制心理侧写。第一份侧写由法医精神病学家罗德·米尔顿（Dr. Rod Milton）博士汇编，他在发现每个犯罪现场时都曾亲临现场。他得出结论称，这些谋杀案遵循相似的模式，是由一个神智清醒的人预谋的。
mind. Yet, the way the bodies were haphazardly covered by forest debris suggested that even though the killer planned to commit the attacks, they may have been ill-prepared when the opportunity actually presented itself. It was clear to Dr. Milton that the perpetrators' acts were driven by a need for power and that they derived pleasure from brutality. After attending Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark's crime scene, Dr. Milton devised a theory that he stuck by throughout the discovery of the remaining victims. As all seven backpackers were killed in a number of different ways, with varying levels of violence, the forensic psychiatrist was certain the murders were not the work of a sole perpetrator, but a killer pair working in tandem.
然而，尸体被森林杂物胡乱掩盖的方式表明，尽管凶手计划实施袭击，但当机会真正出现时，他们可能准备不足。米尔顿博士很清楚，凶手的行为是由对权力的渴望驱动的，他们从残暴中获得快感。在勘查了乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克的犯罪现场后，米尔顿博士提出了一种理论，并在发现其余受害者的全过程里一直坚持这一观点。由于这七名背包客都是以各种不同的方式被杀害的，暴力程度各不相同，这位法医精神病学家确信，这些谋杀案并非单一凶手所为，而是由一对凶手搭档协同作案。
The separation of the paired Balingalo victims indicated the perpetrators sought privacy from one another whilst carrying out their assaults. Her concern typically reserved for offenders who are related. Dr. Milton concluded the killers were brothers, with the eldest being the more dominant of the pair. The frenzied stabbings were probably committed by the rebellious younger brother who wanted to leave a mark, while the calm and controlled older brother used the firearm. Dr. Milton believed the familiarity in which the killers traversed the forest implied they lived locally, possibly together. They were probably low-income earners which compelled them to keep the backpackers' belongings not just the service trophies, but because the items were valuable
贝兰格洛遇害者成对被分开抛尸，表明凶手在实施袭击时试图彼此保持隐私。这种顾虑通常只存在于有亲属关系的罪犯身上。米尔顿博士得出结论，凶手是兄弟俩，其中年龄较大的一个是两人中更具支配地位的一个。疯狂的刺杀可能是那个想要留下痕迹的叛逆弟弟干的，而冷静克制的大哥则使用了枪械。米尔顿博士认为，凶手穿梭于森林时的熟悉程度暗示他们就住在当地，甚至可能住在一起。他们可能收入较低，这迫使他们保留背包客的物品——不仅作为作案战利品，还因为这些物品既有价值
and useful. Their interest in firearms could mean they belonged to a gun club or participated in related hobbies such as hunting. Dr. Milton stressed that profiling was not an exact science and acknowledged the similarities across crime scenes also implied the killer may have acted alone. However, he proposed these commonalities could have been the result of the dominating older brother who had the final word on how the crimes were carried out. Dr. Milton's multi-perpetrator theory was supported by Dr. Richard Basham, a psychological anthropologist who also provided insight into the profile of the Balangelo serial killer. Dr. Basham explained the killer's use of a silencer suggested he
又很实用。他们对枪械的兴趣可能意味着他们属于某个枪击俱乐部，或者参与了诸如狩猎等相关的爱好。米尔顿博士强调，侧写并不是一门精确的科学，他也承认，各个犯罪现场之间的相似之处也暗示凶手可能是单人作案。然而，他提出，这些共同点可能是由占主导地位的大哥造成的，他对犯罪是如何实施的拥有最终决定权。米尔顿博士的“多凶手”理论得到了心理人类学家理查德·巴沙姆（Dr. Richard Basham）博士的支持，他也对贝兰格洛连环杀手的侧写提出了见解。巴沙姆博士解释说，凶手使用消音器表明他
lived in a fantasy world where he viewed himself as an outlaw, and therefore he may own a motorcycle. He believed the perpetrator didn't live in a remote or rural area, otherwise they would have used their own property to carry out the attacks. Although he too was open to differing possibilities, Dr. Basham agreed the separation of the paired victims strongly indicated that more than one killer was involved in the crimes. However, he conceded that a killer acting alone may have divided his victims for control purposes or because he was unable to perform in front of an onlooker. Dr. Basham's theory centered around the belief that the perpetrator began his killing spray alone,
生活在一个幻想世界中，他将自己视为法外之徒，因此他可能拥有一辆摩托车。他认为凶手不住在偏远或乡村地区，否则他们本可以使用自己的私产来实施袭击。尽管他也对其他可能性持开放态度，但巴沙姆同意，成对受害者被分开抛尸强烈表明案件涉及不止一名凶手。不过，他承认，单人作案的凶手也可能为了控制目的而分开受害者，或者因为无法在旁观者面前行凶。巴沙姆博士的理论核心在于，他认为凶手是独自开始连环杀戮的，
then enlisted the help of an accomplice over time. One month after the first victims, James Gibson and Deborah Everest were killed, the lone perpetrator attempted to abduct Paul Onions but failed. Rattled by this misstep, he seemed to have laid low for a year before launching another attack. Simone Schmiddle would have presented as the ideal victim for the killer to resume his spree, as he would have perceived the solo female backpacker as easier to control. Once the killer regained confidence, his focus returned to targeting traveling pairs, but he was now cautious of the risks presented when acting alone. As such, he teamed up with an accomplice for the murders of Gabor Neugebauer and Anja Habsheet,
随后在一段时间内招募了一名同伙的帮助。在第一名受害者詹姆斯·吉布森和黛博拉·埃弗雷斯特被杀一个月后，这个单独作案的凶手试图绑架保罗·尤宁斯但未成功。由于这次失误而感到慌乱，他似乎沉寂了一年，随后才发动了另一次袭击。西蒙妮·施米德尔（Simone Schmidl）本会成为凶手重操旧业的理想受害者，因为他会认为独自一人的女背包客更容易控制。一旦凶手重拾信心，他的注意力便重新回到了针对结伴旅行的人群上，但他现在对独自作案所带来的风险保持着警惕。因此，他与同伙联手谋杀了加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔和安雅·哈布席德，
then Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark. Like Dr. Milton, Dr. Basham agreed the murders could be the work of siblings, saying, I would suspect brothers, particularly if you were talking about crimes of this magnitude. He believed the barbaric act of decapitating Anja was carried out by the more dominant of the two as a statement to the other, proving his power over both victim and subordinate. Experts from the United States Federal Bureau of Investigation formed the contrary opinion, believing the murders were the work of one man, as their study showed it was incredibly rare for two or more serial killers to operate together. Agents from the Bureau's Behavioral Science
随后是乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克。与米尔顿博士一样，巴沙姆博士也认为这些谋杀案可能是兄弟所为，他说道：“我猜是兄弟俩，特别是考虑到你谈论的是如此规模的罪行。”他认为，将安雅斩首的野蛮行径是由两人中更强势的一个实施的，以此作为对另一个人的宣示，向受害者和从属者证明自己的权力。来自美国联邦调查局（FBI）的专家则持相反观点，认为这些谋杀案是一名男子所为，因为他们的研究表明，两名或两名以上的连环杀手共同作案的情况极其罕见。联邦调查局行为科学
Unit helped Australian authorities create a criminal profile of the bilingual serial killer, using their renowned techniques. Their method collated psychological evaluations, case reports, personal histories, and interviews conducted with serial killers to narrow down a suspect's potential age, sex, race, physical build, social habits, and family background. The advanced system, which had a proven success rate of 78 to 80%, identified the bilingual killer as a Caucasian male of strong build, aged between 25 and 45. Although considered a loner who was not very good at establishing close relationships, he was socially adept and came across as friendly and charming to avoid arousing suspicion.
小组的探员们利用其闻名遐迩的技术，协助澳大利亚当局绘制了贝兰格洛连环杀手的犯罪侧写。他们的方法结合了心理评估、案件报告、个人履历以及对连环杀手进行的访谈，以缩小嫌疑人的潜在年龄、性别、种族、体格、社交习惯和家庭背景范围。这个经证实成功率在78%到80%之间的先进系统，将贝兰格洛凶手识别为一名体格健壮、年龄在25岁至45岁之间的白人男性。尽管他被认为是一个不善于建立亲密关系的独行侠，但他具备社交手腕，表现得友好而有魅力，以避免引起怀疑。
He probably held a higher birth order status in his family, possibly the first born son, with a father who had a stable work history. His childhood was inconsistent, marred with troubles at school and then dealings with police during his adolescence. He may have been a back woodsman who spent a lot of time in the bush, either working, hunting, or hiking, and was very comfortable in that environment. In terms of employment, he was a skilled tradesman with an erratic work history, although he may well hold down a steady job. The killer had a preference for high-risk victims, specifically hitchhikers, with no familial connections in the area. His crimes were methodically and carefully planned to deter detection, providing him feelings of superiority, control,
他在家族中可能具有较高的出生顺位，或许是长子，其父亲有着稳定的工作史。他的童年不太稳定，伴随着学校里的麻烦，以及青春期时与警察打交道。他可能是一个常年在森林里活动的人，花很多时间在丛林里工作、打猎或徒步，对那种环境感到非常适应。在职业方面，他是一名有熟练技能的手工业者，工作履历不稳定，尽管他也很可能端着一份稳定的工作。凶手偏爱高风险受害者，具体而言就是没有当地家庭纽带的搭车客。他的罪行是有计划、有条不紊地精心策划以逃避侦查，这为他提供了优越感、控制力
and cleverness. There was a strong chance he kept the belongings of his victims and followed the media reports about his crimes. As all seven backpackers were abducted during holiday periods, including Christmas, the Easter long weekend, or the summer school breaks, profilers believed the killer was propelled to act by some type of situational stress around these times, be it financial, marital, or work related. He would want to elicit a certain reaction from his victims, such as fear or passivity, while stacking out his emotions via torture, mutilation, dismemberment, or other perversions. While he was likely angry or depressed prior to the murders, committing the acts put him in a relaxed mood. When the bureau's detailed
和聪明感。他很有可能保留了受害者的物品，并关注有关其罪行的媒体报道。由于七名背包客都是在度假期间被绑架的，包括圣诞节、复活节长周末或暑假，侧写专家认为，凶手是在这些时期某种生活压力的驱使下才采取行动的，无论是财务、婚姻还是工作方面的压力。他在通过折磨、肢解、分尸或其他变态行为发泄情绪的同时，会希望从受害者身上激发出某种特定的反应，比如恐惧或顺从。虽然他在谋杀前可能感到愤怒或沮丧，但犯下这些罪行让他进入了一种放松的心情。当联邦调查局关于贝兰格洛连环杀手的详细
profile of the Balingalos serial killer was released to the public and media, it caused some criminal experts to express concern. They believed that the increased attention might provoke an unfamiliar sense of desperation in the perpetrator, leading him to explode and conduct one final murder spree. Knowing it was only a matter of time before he was caught, he may intentionally put himself in a situation that forced the police to wend his life, rather than allow himself to be arrested and face punishment. When asked for his prediction, FBI Special Agent Les Davis warned, in all likelihood, he will kill again. Around Easter of 1992, months before any of the Balingalos victims had been found, news of the
侧写向公众和媒体公布时，它引起了一些犯罪专家们的担忧。他们认为，日益增加的关注可能会在凶手心中激起一种陌生而绝望的情绪，导致他情绪爆发并进行最后一次连环杀戮。他知道自己被抓只是时间问题，因此可能会故意将自己置于迫使警方了结其性命的境地，而不是让自己被捕并面对惩罚。当被问及他的预测时，联邦调查局特别探员莱斯·戴维斯（Les Davis）警告说：“按所有可能性来看，他会再次杀人。”在大约1992年的复活节，即任何贝兰格洛受害者被发现之前的几个月里，几名外国背包客失踪的
disappearance of several foreign backpackers was the topic of conversation at building supply company Borrow Industries. Employee 38-year-old Richard Millatt was described as a quiet man, but was known to become more talkative when he smoked cannabis. As his workmates discussed the missing backpackers, Richard, who was clearly under the influence of marijuana, allegedly commented to his colleague, Des Butler, I know who killed the Germans. Months later, in September 1992, the murders of Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark were being discussed around the workplace. During one conversation about the crime, a stoned Richard allegedly told another colleague, Paul Douglas. There are two Germans out there. They haven't found them yet.
消息成了建筑材料公司博罗工业公司（Borrow Industries）里谈论的话题。38岁的员工理查德·米拉特（Richard Millatt）被形容为一个安静的人，但据称他在吸食大麻时会变得比较健谈。当他的工友们讨论失踪的背包客时，明显处于大麻影响下的理查德据称对他的同事德斯·巴特勒（Des Butler）评论道：“我知道是谁杀了德国人。”几个月后，即1992年9月，乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克的谋杀案正在工作场所被讨论。在一次关于这起罪行的讨论中，处于大麻幻觉中的理查德据称对另一位同事保罗·道格拉斯（Paul Douglas）说道：“外面还有两个德国人。他们还没找到他们。”
Later that day, during a discussion about Joanne and Caroline's known plans to hitchhike south along the Hume Highway, Richard allegedly remarked, you could pick up anybody on that road and you'd never find them again. You'd never find out who did it either. A few weeks later, the topic came up again, during which Richard allegedly stated, there are more bodies out there. They haven't found them all yet. A year later, shortly after James Gibson and Deborah Everest's remains were uncovered in Balingalo, an unrelated rape case was making national news. Richard Millatt was discussing the news story at work when, according to Paul Douglas, he allegedly remarked, stabbing a woman is like cutting a loaf of bread.
那天晚些时候，在讨论乔安妮和卡罗琳沿着休姆湖南下搭便车的既定计划时，理查德据称评论道：“你在那条路上可以随便载任何人，你永远也找不到他们了。你也永远不会查出是谁干的。”几周后，这个话题再次被提起，期间理查德据称声称：“外面还有更多尸体。他们还没把他们全找到。”一年后，在詹姆斯·吉布森和黛博拉·埃弗雷斯特的遗体在贝兰格洛被发掘出不久后，一桩不相关的强奸案成了全国新闻。据保罗·道格拉斯称，理查德·米拉特正在工作中讨论这则新闻故事时，据称评论道：“捅女人就像切一条面包一样。”
Paul was taken aback by the sinister remark, but shrugged it off, as Richard's bizarre comments were widely considered to be nothing more than drug-induced ramblings. It wasn't until the final three Balingalo victims were discovered, German citizens Simone Schmidl, Gabor Neugebauer and Daniel Habschede, that Paul felt uneasy, recalling the time Richard allegedly claimed that they hadn't found the Germans yet. Paul voiced his concerns to fellow colleague Des Butler, who was reminded of his own strange conversation with Richard, during which the man allegedly made the ominous statement, I know who killed the Germans. Des Butler called the crime stoppers hotline,
保罗对这个阴险的言论感到吃惊，但耸耸肩没放在心上，因为理查德那些古怪的言论在大家看来不过是吸毒后的胡言乱语。直到贝兰格洛最后三名受害者——德国公民西蒙妮·施米德尔、加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔和达尼埃尔·哈布席德（Daniel Habschede）被发现时，保罗才感到不安，他回想起理查德曾经声称“他们还没找到德国人”的那次谈话。保罗向同事德斯·巴特勒表达了他的担忧，这让德斯想起了自己与理查德的那次奇怪对话，当时这个人据称说出了那句不祥的话：“我知道是谁杀了德国人。”德斯·巴特勒拨打了灭罪热线，
as his wife passed on Richard Millatt's details to a detective she knew personally. A background check revealed Richard had prior convictions for breaking and entering theft, cannabis possession and various traffic offences. As a precaution, his details were handed over to Task Force Air. The Millatt name had actually been on Task Force Air's radar since mid-October 1993, when only four of the seven Balingalo victims had been found. During investigations at the time, detectives visited the pistol club in Bowerl, the community on Balingalo's outskirts, where a club leader advised them to speak to one of their members named Alexander Millatt. The 53-year-old, who went by Alex, attended Bowerl police station two days later to detail an
他的妻子将理查德·米拉特的个人信息转达给了一位她私下认识的侦探。背景调查显示，理查德有持械入室盗窃、持有大麻以及各种交通违章的前科。作为预防措施，他的信息被移交给“空中特遣队”。事实上，“米拉特”这个姓氏早在1993年10月中旬就已经进入了空中特遣队的视线，当时七名贝兰格洛受害者中才找到了四人。在当时调查期间，侦探们走访了位于贝兰格洛郊区社区鲍拉尔的手枪俱乐部，俱乐部负责人建议他们与一位名叫亚历山大·米拉特（Alexander Millatt）的会员谈谈。这位53岁、大家都叫他亚历克斯（Alex）的男子于两天后前往鲍拉尔警察局，详细说明了他在
incident he witnessed on April 26, 1992, one week after British backpackers Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark went missing. Whilst driving home from the pistol club with a friend, Alex passed two vehicles, a brown Ford Falcon sedan and a brown four-wheel drive. The two vehicles were entering the access road into Balingalo State Forest. Both vehicles contained several male occupants, with one woman positioned in the back seat of each vehicle between two men. Upon passing the vehicles, Alex made eye contact with the women who were gagged and frightened. He could no longer recall the vehicle's license plate numbers, but was able to provide an extraordinary level of detail in his descriptions of the men in the cars, including their complexions,
1992年4月26日（英国背包客乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克失踪一周后）目击的一起事件。亚历克斯和朋友从手枪俱乐部开车回家时，路过了两辆车：一辆棕色福特猎鹰（Ford Falcon）轿车和一辆棕色四轮驱动车。这两辆车正驶入通往贝兰格洛州立森林的便道。两辆车里都坐着几个男性乘客，每辆车的后座上都在两个男人中间夹着一个女人。在驶过这些车辆时，亚历克斯与那些被堵住嘴且面露惊恐的女性进行了眼神交流。他已经记不清车辆的车牌号了，但能够极其详细地描述车内男子的特征，包括他们的肤色、
hairstyles and tattoos. When asked why he didn't think to report this incident to the police when it happened, or after Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark's remains were found, Alex Millatt explained he thought it was, quote, just some young blokes taking some girls into the forest to have a good time. Detectives questioned Alex's driving companion, Bill Ayers, who also witnessed the two vehicles heading into Balingalo that day, but Bill could not corroborate Alex's account of the two restrained women. Alex's statement raised many questions for the head of Task Force Air, Superintendent Clive Small, who later commented in his book Inside Australia's Biggest Manhunt. Given he had been looking through the window of a moving vehicle, the level of detail in
发型和纹身。当被问及为什么在事情发生时，或者在乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克的遗体被找到后，没有想到向警方报告这起事件时，亚历克斯·米拉特解释说他以为那是“几个年轻小伙子带几个女孩进森林去寻欢作乐”。侦探们讯问了亚历克斯的同车同伴比尔·艾尔斯（Bill Ayers），他也目击了那两辆车当天驶往贝兰格洛的情景，但比尔无法证实亚历克斯关于那两个被控制的女性的说法。亚历克斯的供词给空中特遣队负责人克莱夫·斯莫尔（Clive Small）警司带来了许多疑问，他后来在其著作《深入澳大利亚最大的搜捕行动》（Inside Australia's Biggest Manhunt）中评论道：“考虑到他是透过一辆行驶中的车辆的车窗看出去的，亚历克斯证词中的细节详细得惊人，甚至可以说是离奇。
Alex's statement was extraordinary, not to say bizarre. Questions began to pile up in my mind. Was it a complete fabrication? If so, what was Alex's motive? Was Alex involved in the murders and playing a game with the Task Force? Did Alex know something about the murders, and was he trying to tell the Task Force something without coming out directly and providing that information? Alex's statement was passed between Task Force Air Detectives over the course of the investigation, until one recognized the Millatt surname from other tip-offs provided by the public. Alex's younger brother Richard had been named dropped to investigators for the chewing remarks he allegedly made to co-workers about the
我的脑海中开始涌现出一个个疑问。这完全是捏造的吗？如果是这样，亚历克斯的动机是什么？亚历克斯是否参与了谋杀并在和特遣队玩游戏？亚历克斯是否知道一些关于谋杀案的事情，他是不是想在不直接说出来提供那些信息的情况下，试着向特遣队透露点什么？”在整个调查过程中，亚历克斯的供词在空中特遣队的侦探们手中辗转流传，直到其中一人从公众提供的其他线索中认出了“米拉特”这个姓氏。亚历克斯的弟弟理查德曾因其在谋杀案发生后对同事所作的那些令人毛骨悚然的言论而被线人提及。而第三个米拉特兄弟伊万（Ivan）也通过热线被点名，因为他的亲属在离贝兰格洛不远的地方拥有房产，开着一辆四轮驱动车，并拥有好几支枪。
murders. And a third Millatt brother, Ivan, had been named through the hotline, as he had family with property not far from Balingalo, drove a four-wheel drive, and possessed several firearms. Curious to discover what else they could find about the three siblings, a team of five detectives were tasked to conduct a further investigation into the Millatt family. As described in the book Sins of the Brother by Mark Whittaker and Delez Kennedy, the Millatt family was extensive, consisting of 14 children in total, 10 sons, and four daughters. The family's patriarch, Stephen Millatt, moved to Sydney from Croatia in 1926, seeking better employment prospects. In 1934, 32-year-old Stephen was walking along the street
为了探究他们还能发现这三兄弟的什么信息，一个由五名侦探组成的团队奉命对米拉特家族展开进一步调查。正如马克·惠特克（Mark Whittaker）和德勒兹·肯尼迪（Delez Kennedy）在《兄弟之罪》（Sins of the Brother）一书中所述，米拉特家族是个庞大的家族，总共有14个孩子，其中10个儿子，4个女儿。家族大家长斯蒂芬·米拉特（Stephen Millatt）于1926年为寻求更好的就业前景，从克罗地亚移居悉尼。1934年，32岁的斯蒂芬正走在街上，
when a 14-year-old girl named Margaret Piddleston rode into him on her bicycle. Margaret invited Stephen back to her home for a cup of tea, and the two started spending time together reading, listening to the radio, and going to the movies. Stephen proposed to Margaret when she was 15 years old, and to the pair were married in her parents' backyard a year later. The newlyweds moved to a small flat in a working-class suburb of Sydney, where Stephen laboured as a warfee on the harbour's waterfront. In 1937, they relocated to the rural area of Keenley Vale to a property with no electricity or plumbing. Their first child, Olga, was born two years later, followed by 13 more children over the next 23 years. Alexander, Boris, Mary, Ivan, Shirley, William, Michael, Walter, George,
这时一个名叫玛格丽特·皮德尔斯顿（Margaret Piddleston）的14岁女孩骑着自行车撞到了他。玛格丽特邀请斯蒂芬去她家喝杯茶，两人开始一起度过时光：读书、听广播、看电影。玛格丽特15岁时，斯蒂芬向她求婚，一年后两人在女方父母的后院结婚了。这对新婚夫妇搬到了悉尼一个工人阶级郊区的小公寓里，斯蒂芬在海港滨水区当码头工人。1937年，他们搬到了基恩利维尔（Keenley Vale）的农村地区，住进了一处没有电也没有管道设施的房产。他们的第一个孩子奥尔加（Olga）于两年后出生，随后在接下来的23年里又迎来了13个孩子。亚历山大、鲍里斯、玛丽、伊万、雪莉、威廉、迈克尔、沃尔特、乔治、
Margaret, Richard, David, and Paul. At one stage, Stephen partnered with his father-in-law to establish a market garden that ultimately provided him enough money to buy a significant block of land in the southwest Sydney suburb of Moorbank in the Liverpool district. He quit working on the wharves and with the help of his many children, grew tomatoes, cabbages, and other vegetables. Although their garden was successful, the Malat family remained on the poverty line, living in a two-room shack with dirt-packed floors where everyone worked long hours sustaining the crops and slept on the ground. Stephen started drinking heavily and was prone to violent outbursts at his wife and children, with neighbours describing him as a brute. When Stephen was 52, his entire
玛格丽特、理查德、大卫和保罗。有一段时间，斯蒂芬与他的岳父合伙建立了一个菜园，这最终为他提供了足够的资金，在利物浦地区的悉尼西南部郊区穆尔班克（Moorbank）买下了一大块土地。他辞去了码头的工作，在众多孩子的帮助下种植西红柿、卷心菜和其他蔬菜。尽管他们的菜园很成功，但米拉特一家依然处于贫困线以下，挤在泥土地面的两间小屋里，所有人都要工作很长时间来维持作物的生长，并睡在地上。斯蒂芬开始酗酒，并对妻子和孩子大打出手，邻居们形容他是个粗野暴徒。斯蒂芬52岁时，他的整批
harvest of tomatoes was stolen in the middle of the night, prompting him to give up gardening and accept a job working 12-hour shifts as a labourer for a concrete manufacturer. Each day, he walked the 20-kilometre round trip to his new workplace, giving the Malat children plenty of time without the supervision and discipline of their father. The Malat siblings had spent so much of their youth working in their father's gardens that they had socialised very little with other children. Many days were spent exploring the bush surrounding their rural property, where they shot targets, rabbits, and birds. The Malat brothers attended a Catholic high school in Liverpool where their teachers were known to hand out disciplinary beatings,
西红柿在半夜被偷了，这促使他放弃了园艺工作，转而接受了一份为混凝土制造商做劳工、需要进行12小时轮班的工作。每天，他都要步行完成往返新工作地点共20公里的路程，这给米拉特的孩子们留出了大量没有父亲监督和管教的时间。米拉特兄弟把大量的童年时光都花在了父亲的菜园里干活，以至于他们与其他孩子的社交非常少。许多日子都在他们农村房产周围的丛林中探索度过，在那里他们练习射击标靶、兔子和鸟类。米拉特兄弟就读于利物浦的一所天主教高中，那里的老师以体罚学生而闻名，
leading the boys to have a disdain for authority figures. Several developed a reputation for getting into fights, skipping class, and finding themselves in trouble with the law. Every couple of days, the police would appear on Margaret Malat's doorstep to report some kind of incident involving her sons. The mother was quick to defend her children, insisting the officers had made a mistake and naming other children in the neighbourhood as the ones to blame. Margaret would then withhold the boys misbehaviour from their father to spare them from harsh punishment. In 1969, Stephen and Margaret Malat sold the Moorbank property and bought a house on Campbell Hill Road in the western Sydney suburb of Guildford,
导致这些男孩对权威人物产生了蔑视。其中几人养成了打架、逃课并陷入法律麻烦的不良名声。每隔几天，警察就会出现在玛格丽特·米拉特的门廊前，报告涉及她儿子的某种事件。这位母亲很快为她的孩子们辩护，坚信警官们弄错了，并指出邻里中的其他孩子才是该责备的人。玛格丽特随后会向孩子们的父亲隐瞒男孩们的恶劣行为，以免他们受到严厉惩罚。1969年，斯蒂芬和玛格丽特·米拉特卖掉了穆尔班克的那处房产，并在悉尼西部吉尔福德（Guildford）郊区的坎贝尔山路（Campbell Hill Road）买下了一栋房子，
where many of their children remained well into their adult years. In 1971, their youngest daughter, 16-year-old Margaret, was killed in a car accident just one kilometre from the family home while her brother Walter was behind to the wheel. The loss had a devastating impact on the family. Just over a decade later, in 1983, Stephen Malat died of cancer at the age of 81. By 1993, many of the Malat siblings still lived in the southwest Sydney area, and some resided in the southern Highlands region. A cursory background check into the Malat family revealed some members had criminal records ranging from minor traffic offences to more serious crimes including extortion and armed robbery.
他们的许多孩子在那里一直住到了成年。1971年，他们最小的女儿、16岁的玛格丽特在距离家族住所仅一公里处的一场车祸中丧生，当时驾驶方向盘的是她的哥哥沃尔特。这一损失对这个家庭造成了毁灭性的打击。仅仅十多年后的1983年，斯蒂芬·米拉特因癌症去世，享年81岁。到了1993年，许多米拉特兄弟姐妹仍然住在悉尼西南部地区，其中一些人则居住在南部高地（Southern Highlands）地区。对米拉特家族进行的粗略背景调查显示，有些成员有犯罪记录，从轻微交通违章到更严重的犯罪（包括敲诈勒索和持械抢劫）不等。
One of the more problematic Malat sons, Ivan, was a loner who had a proclivity towards antisocial and criminal behaviour from a young age. At 13 years old, he was sent to a residential school for adolescent boys with behavioural issues, but it had little impact on curbing his troublesome ways. When he returned home a year later, Ivan began committing thefts and break-ins, resulting in a six-month stint in a juvenile detention centre at age 17. In 1963, 19-year-old Ivan broke into a shop and stole a car battery, but managed to flee the scene before police arrived. Officers found Ivan's older brother Boris waiting in a car nearby and subsequently charged him for the robbery. Boris refused to name his accomplice, and his
Malat 兄弟中比较让人头疼的一个是伊万，他是个独行侠，从小就有反社会和犯罪倾向。13 岁时，他被送往一所专门收容有行为问题青少年的寄宿学校，但这对他改掉毛病几乎没什么作用。一年后他回到家中，开始行窃和入室盗窃，17 岁时因此在少管所呆了六个月。1963 年，19 岁的伊万闯入一家店铺偷了一块汽车电瓶，但在警察赶到之前设法逃离了现场。警官们发现伊万的大哥鲍里斯正坐在附近的一辆车里等候，随即便以抢劫罪起诉了他。鲍里斯拒绝说出同伙的名字，而他的
loyalty ensured Ivan went unpunished. The following year, Ivan received his first adult conviction for break and enter, and was sentenced to 18 months in prison. A month after his parole, Ivan and his brother William, or Bill as he was known, were arrested for driving a stolen car. Ivan went on the run prior to court proceedings, leaving Bill to face an 18-month prison term for the crime. With the help of his mother, Ivan was able to evade police detection for several months before his eventual capture. In court, Boris Malat perched himself on the witness stand in an attempt to provide his brother a false alibi, but Ivan was found guilty and sentenced to two years' hard labour at the notoriously rough, graft and maximum security prison.
这份义气确保了伊万免受惩罚。第二年，伊万因入室盗窃迎来了他的第一次成人定罪，被判处 18 个月监禁。假释一个月后，伊万和他的弟弟威廉（人称比尔）因驾驶一辆盗窃车而被捕。在法院审理之前，伊万潜逃了，留下比尔独自承担因该罪行被判处的 18 个月监禁。在母亲的帮助下，伊万在最终被捕前成功躲避了警方几个月的搜捕。在法庭上，鲍里斯·马拉特站在证人席上，企图为他的弟弟提供不在场假证明，但伊万仍被判有罪，并被判处两年重劳役，关押在臭名昭著、腐败且戒备森严的监狱里。
After being released on parole in April 1967, Ivan commenced work for the Roads and Traffic Authority in Liverpool. Five months later, he and his brother Michael were found guilty of theft. Michael was sentenced to two years, while 22-year-old Ivan was sentenced to three. While Ivan and Michael served time, several other Malats were getting into their own troubles, having developed a formidable reputation around town. They were fiercely loyal and protective of one another. Yet, Ivan didn't treat his brothers with the same level of respect they showed him, instigating romantic affairs with several of their partners. In 1975, 30-year-old Ivan began work as a driver for a Liverpool-based trucking company.
1967 年 4 月获得假释后，伊万开始在利物浦的道路和交通管理局工作。五个月后，他和弟弟迈克尔因盗窃罪被判有罪。迈克尔被判两年，而 22 岁的伊万则被判三年。在伊万和迈克尔服刑期间，其他几个马拉特兄弟也麻烦不断，在镇上树立了令人敬畏的名声。他们极其忠诚，并且彼此护短。然而，伊万并没有以他们对待他的那种尊重来对待兄弟们，反而插足了他们好几个伴侣的感情。1975 年，30 岁的伊万开始在利物浦的一家卡车运输公司担任司机。
A majority of his runs were along the Hume Highway to places like Galbin, Canberra and Yass, but he was also given several long-haul interstate jobs to Melbourne, Brisbane, Perth, Adelaide and to the Gold Coast. Ivan was introduced to a 16-year-old girl named Karen, who had fallen pregnant to one of his cousins just six weeks earlier. This didn't stop Ivan from pursuing a relationship with the teenager. On their first date, Ivan grabbed Karen by the throat and raped her. After Karen forgave Ivan for the act, the two officially became a couple, remaining together after the birth of Karen's son and moving into a caravan in the backyard of the Malat family home in Guildford. In October 1976, 31-year-old Ivan left his truck-driving job
他的大部分路线都是沿着休姆高速公路前往加尔宾、堪培拉和亚斯等地，但他也承担了几次开往墨尔本、布里斯班、珀斯、阿德莱德和黄金海岸的长途跨州运输任务。伊万经人介绍认识了一个名叫凯伦的 16 岁女孩，她就在六个月前刚刚怀上了他一个表弟的孩子。但这并没有阻止伊万对这个青少年的追求。在他们的第一次约会上，伊万掐住凯伦的喉咙并强暴了她。在凯伦原谅了伊万的这一行径后，两人正式确立了恋爱关系，在凯伦的儿子出生后依然在一起，并搬进了吉尔福德马拉特家族住宅后院的一辆大篷车里。1976 年 10 月，31 岁的伊万辞去了卡车司机的工作，
and went back to working for the Roads and Traffic Authority, which sent him across the state for weeks at a time to places like the Hunter Valley, Lithgow, Newcastle, the Blue Mountains and down the South Coast. He spent his spare time on shooting trips with his brothers or meticulously working on his car, constantly polishing, washing and evacuming it. He was also dedicated to maintaining his strong physique, keeping in shape by lifting homemade weights he had constructed out of metal pipes and buckets of cement. By 1981, Ivan bought a house in the greater Western Sydney suburb of Blackett. He had become increasingly controlling of Karen, isolating her and forbidding her from associating with her friends or family. They married at the registry in 1983, leading Karen to lose
重新回到道路和交通管理局工作，这让他被派往全州各地，一去就是几周，目的地包括亨特谷、利思戈、纽卡斯尔、蓝山以及南海岸。他把闲暇时间花和兄弟们一起打猎上，或者一丝不苟地打理他的汽车，不断地抛光、清洗和吸尘。他还致力于保持强健的体格，通过举起用金属管和水泥桶自制的哑铃来保持身材。到 1981 年，伊万在大悉尼西部的布莱克特郊区买了一栋房子。他对凯伦的控制欲越来越强，将她孤立起来，禁止她与朋友或家人交往。他们在 1983 年进行了登记结婚，导致凯伦失去了
her single mother pension and rely solely on Ivan's income, for which he demanded she account for every single cent she spent. Following the death of his father in 1983, the physical, emotional and sexual abuse Ivan inflicted on his wife worsened, with the smallest thing setting him off. After his violent outbursts, Ivan would spend several days at his mother's house, threatening never to return to Karen. Around this time, workmates noticed Ivan started reading gun magazines and carrying a pistol, which he kept either tucked into his boots or underneath the driver's seat of his car. After a wave of robberies hit the Blackett area, Ivan became obsessed with security and started a neighborhood watch program. He even bought an
单亲母亲抚养金，只能完全依靠伊万的收入生活，而伊万要求她对花掉的每一分钱都要记账。1983 年父亲去世后，伊万对妻子施加的身体、情感和性虐待变本加厉，哪怕是最微小的事情也能激怒他。在暴力发作后，伊万会在母亲家呆上好几天，扬言再也不回凯伦身边。大约在这个时候，同事们注意到伊万开始阅读枪械杂志并随身携带手枪，他把手枪塞在靴子里或放在汽车驾驶座底下。在布莱克特地区爆发了一波抢劫潮后，伊万对安防产生了执念，并开始了一个社区守望计划。他甚至买了一套
engraving kit, imprinting his name on all of his possessions, from valuable items to the kitchen toaster. In early 1987, Ivan threw a glass at Karen that narrowly missed hitting her young son. This was the tipping point for Karen, and the next time Ivan was away for work, she packed up and left. Devastated by his wife's departure, Ivan refused to return to their home in Blackett, moving in with his mother in Guildford. He sold the Blackett property for well under market value, forging Karen's signature on documents to facilitate the quick sale. He refused to give her any of the payout, instead using some of the money to buy himself a silver Nissan Patrol four-wheel drive, registering it under the name of his brother, Bill.
雕刻工具，在自己的所有财物上印上名字，从贵重物品到厨房里的烤面包机无一例外。1987 年初，伊万向凯伦扔了一个玻璃杯，差一点就砸中了她年幼的儿子。这是压垮凯伦的最后一根稻草，趁着下次伊万出差外地，她收拾行李离开了。妻子离去让伊万备受打击，他拒绝回到布莱克特的家中，搬去吉尔福德与母亲同住。他以远低于市场价的价格卖掉了布莱克特的房产，并在文件上伪造了凯伦的签名以促成快速交易。他拒绝给她任何变现所得，反而用部分钱为自己买了一辆银色的日产途乐四驱车，并以他弟弟比尔的名义登记注册。
A year after Ivan and Karen's separation, a fire broke out in her parents' garage that destroyed all of its contents, including two vehicles. Ivan was questioned, as he had previously threatened to burn their house down if they didn't tell him where Karen was now living. He denied all responsibility, and as there was no solid proof linking him to the arson, no charges were filed. The roads and traffic authority started garnishing Ivan's wage in order to provide maintenance payments to Karen, motivating him to quit his job after 12 years of service to avoid her getting a cent of his money. He then used his brother Bill's name and birth date for his next two jobs to avoid having his wages docked for spouse or support payments.
在伊万和凯伦分居一年后，她父母的车库突发一场大火，里面的所有物品（包括两辆车）付之一炬。伊万受到了盘问，因为他此前曾威胁说，如果他们不告诉他凯伦现在的住处，就要放火烧了他们的房子。他否认了所有责任，由于没有确凿证据将他与纵火案联系起来，警方没有对他提出指控。道路和交通管理局开始扣发伊万的工资，以便向凯伦支付赡养费，这促使他在工作了 12 年后辞职，以免凯伦拿到他的一分钱。随后，他在接下来的两份工作中使用了他弟弟比尔的名字和出生日期，以避免工资被扣用于配偶或抚养费。
Meanwhile, Ivan reignited a relationship with an old flame, a woman named Marilyn. The two had a long and sordid history that began when Ivan was 19 years old, first becoming romantically involved while Marilyn was in a relationship with Ivan's older brother, Boris. Their affairs banned years, resulting in the birth of a daughter and generating an abundance of tension within the Malat family. In 1971, Marilyn chose to marry Boris, officially ending things with Ivan and leaving him heartbroken. As both of their marriages had since failed, the former lovers reconnected and started spending their weekends together, driving to remote areas where Ivan would shoot birds and other targets.
与此同时，伊万重燃了与旧爱玛丽莲的恋情。两人的纠葛旷日持久且声名狼藉，始于伊万 19岁那年，当时玛丽莲正与伊万的大哥鲍里斯恋爱，他们便首次产生了浪漫情愫。这段婚外情持续了多年，导致了一个女儿的出生，并在马拉特家族内部制造了大量的紧张气氛。1971 年，玛丽莲选择嫁给鲍里斯，正式结束了与伊万的关系，让他心碎不已。由于两人的婚姻后来都破裂了，这对昔日的恋人重新联系上，并开始一起度过周末，开车前往偏远地区，伊万会在那里射击鸟类和其他目标。
Marilyn noted a change in Ivan's personality. He had developed a hardened edge and violent temper, seemingly taking pleasure in the suffering of the creatures he hunted. In August of 1989, Marilyn ended their relationship for a second time after Ivan admitted he had no desire to marry again. The breakup left Ivan devastated. Two months later, his divorce from Karen was finalised and as he was no longer financially indebted to his ex-wife, he returned to work at the Rhodes and Traffic Authority. In June 1992, Ivan's sister Shirley introduced him to a woman named Chalinda and the two became a couple. Their relationship came as a surprise to some as Chalinda was of Indian heritage and Ivan had a reputation for being racist.
玛丽莲注意到伊万的性格变了。他变得冷酷无情、脾气暴烈，似乎从他猎杀的生物的痛苦中获得快感。1989 年 8 月，在伊万承认自己不想再次结婚后，玛丽莲第二次结束了他们的关系。这次分手让伊万痛不欲生。两个月后，他与凯伦的离婚手续办妥了，由于他不再在经济上亏欠前妻，他回到了道路和交通管理局工作。1992 年 6 月，伊万的姐姐雪莉把他介绍给了一个名叫查琳达的女人，两人成为了一对。他们的关系让一些人感到意外，因为查琳达具有印度血统，而伊万一向有种族主义的名声。
But Chalinda's influence seemed to have a positive effect on Ivan. Hyenty's sister Shirley bought a piece of land on Cinnabar Street in the southwest Sydney suburb of Eaglevale, building a single-story, four-bedroom brick veneer home just 350 metres away from the Hume Highway and 88 kilometres north of Balangelo. Having piqued their interest, task force air detectives conducted a background check on Ivan Malat but found nothing in their modern computer computerised records that fit the behavioural profile of the Balangelo serial killer. To cover all bases, Superintendent Clive Small ordered Detective Paul Gordon to manually check the old microfilm database that stored pre-1984 criminal records. As Detective Gordon searched
但查琳达的影响似乎对伊万产生了积极的影响。伊万的姐姐雪莉在悉尼西南部伊格尔维尔郊区的辰砂街买了一块地，建造了一栋单层、四卧室的砖饰面住宅，距离休姆高速公路仅 350 米，距离巴兰格洛以北 88 公里。空气特遣队的侦探们被激起了兴趣，对伊万·马拉特进行了背景调查，但在他们现代化的计算机记录中没有发现任何符合巴兰格洛连环杀手行为特征的记录。为了不遗漏任何线索，克莱夫·斯莫尔总警司命令保罗·戈登侦探手动查阅存储了 1984 年以前犯罪记录的旧缩微胶片数据库。正当戈登侦探搜寻
the antiquated system, Ivan Malat's name came up in relation to a crime that occurred in 1971, when he was 27 years old. The discovery prompted Detective Gordon to race into Superintendent Small's office and inform his leader. He's our man. He did it. On April 9, 1971, two decades before the seven murdered backpackers were discovered in Balangelo, 18-year-olds Grace and Marissa, not their real names, started on foot from Liverpool towards the Hume Highway. They planned to hitchhike south to Melbourne to visit Grace's mother. They had barely ventured far from the train station when a car pulled up beside them. The male driver explained he was heading south and offered to take the pair part of the way to
这个过时的系统时，伊万·马拉特的名字因涉及一起发生于 1971 年的罪案而浮出水面，当时他 27 岁。这一发现促使戈登侦探冲进斯莫尔总警司的办公室，向长官汇报情况。他就是我们要找的人。他干的。1971 年 4 月 9 日，在巴兰格洛发现七名被谋杀的背包客的两十年前，18 岁的格蕾丝和玛丽莎（化名）从利物浦步行出发，前往休姆高速公路。她们计划搭便车向南去墨尔本看望格蕾丝的母亲。她们刚走出火车站不远，一辆车就在她们身旁停了下来。男司机解释说他要往南走，并主动提出带两人走一段去
Melbourne. Grace and Marissa gratefully accepted the ride and climbed into the car. Marissa had taken three sleeping pills and soon crashed out in the back seat. Grace, who was riding in the passenger seat, had taken a valium and she too eventually dozed off. When the young women awoke a while later, they realised they were no longer on the Hume Highway, but instead parked down a gravel road. Their driver turned to them and said, I'm going to have sex with both of you, before threatening to kill them if they didn't obey. Grace attempted to reason with the man, stating she and Marissa were both psychiatric patients undergoing treatment for sex-related disorders. Urging him to leave them alone, Grace mentioned
墨尔本的路。格蕾丝和玛丽莎感激地接受了搭车请求，爬上了车。玛丽莎吃了三片安眠药，很快就在后座上睡着了。坐在副驾驶座上的格蕾丝吃了一片安定，最终也迷迷糊糊地睡着了。过了一会儿，当年轻的女性醒来时，她们意识到自己已经不在休姆高速公路上，而是停在了一条砂石路上。司机转过身对她们说，我要和你们两个发生性关系，随后威胁说如果不听话就杀了她们。格蕾丝试图跟这个男人讲道理，声称她和玛丽莎都是正在接受与性相关疾病治疗的精神病患者。格蕾丝敦促他放过她们，并提到了
God, causing the man to explain that he no longer believed in God because his 16-year-old sister had been killed in a car accident. They argued back and forth for some time before Grace said she was going to be sick and tried to get out of the car, but the man grabbed her by the neck. He pulled out two knives and two lengths of nylon cord, again threatening to kill the women if they refused to have sex with him. Marissa promised they wouldn't go to the police if he just let them go, giving him permission to tie them up so he could get away. He bound Grace by the hands and feet, then started to restrain Marissa, telling her, You know what I'm going to do. I'm going to kill the both of you. You won't scream when I cut your throats, will you? Either one of you has sex with
上帝，这引得该男子解释说他不再相信上帝，因为他 16 岁的妹妹在车祸中丧生了。两人来来回回争论了一会儿，接着格蕾丝说她要吐了并试图下车，但该男子一把揪住她的脖子。他掏出两把刀和两段尼龙绳，再次威胁说如果她们拒绝与他发生性关系就杀了她们。玛丽莎承诺只要他放她们走，她们就不会报警，并允许他把她们捆起来以便他脱身。他把格蕾丝的手脚绑起来，然后开始控制玛丽莎，对她说：“你知道我要做什么。我要杀了你们两个。当我割断你们的喉咙时，你们不会尖叫的，对吧？你们两个要么跟我发生性关系，
me, or I will kill you both. Terrified and desperate, Marissa complied with her assailant's demands. Grace was ordered to keep lookout as the man proceeded to rape Marissa inside his vehicle. Afterwards, he told them they would all sleep together in the car, but Grace complained she was still feeling sick. He agreed to take the young women to get a drink, driving them into the nearby regional town of Gulban before pulling into a BP service station. Grace remained in the car with their abductor as Marissa rented the store alone. Once inside, she proceeded to inform a staff member about her ordeal and explained that her attacker was armed with a knife. The attendant wanted to call the police,
要么我把你们俩都杀掉。”惊恐绝望的玛丽莎顺从了施暴者的要求。格蕾丝被命令放哨，而这个男人则在车内强暴了玛丽莎。事后，他告诉她们所有人将一起睡在车里，但格蕾丝抱怨说她还是觉得不舒服。他同意带年轻女子去买点喝的，开车把她们带到附近的区域小镇加尔班，然后驶入一家BP加油站。格蕾丝和绑架者留在车里，而玛丽莎独自一人走进商店。一进去，她就开始向一名员工讲述自己的遭遇，并解释说她的袭击者持有武器——一把刀。店员想报警，
but Marissa urged her not to as her friend was still in danger. At that point, the man entered the service station to ask Marissa if she needed more money. They purchased three cans of soft drink and then walked outside to his car. Unbeknownst to either of them, a group of men had overheard Marissa speaking to the attendant and followed her out of the store. Their presence gave the two young women the confidence to execute an escape and they both ran from the car. Their assailant drove off, heading northward along the Hume Highway. Police were contacted and a patrol car scouting the highway spotted the suspect's vehicle and attempted to pull it over. The driver hit the accelerator and sped away,
但玛丽莎催促她不要报警，因为她的朋友还在危险之中。就在那时，那名男子进入加油站询问玛丽莎是否需要更多钱。他们买了三罐软饮料，然后走到外面的车里。他们谁也不知道，有一群男人无意中听到玛丽莎跟店员说话，并跟着她走出了商店。他们的存在给了两个年轻女子逃跑的信心，两人从车里跑开。袭击者驾车离去，沿着休姆高速公路向北驶去。警方接到报案，在高速公路上巡逻的一辆警车发现了嫌疑人的车辆并试图将其拦下。司机猛踩油门加速逃跑，
only to be brought to a stop by a police roadblock that had been assembled a little further up the road. Upon his arrest, the suspect was identified as 27-year-old Ivan Malat. He denied raping Marissa, insisting it was a consensual act. The two survivors were taken to Goldman Hospital for treatment and although the doctors found no bruises or injuries on Marissa, there were red marks around Grace's wrist consistent with her having been restrained. Police searched Ivan's car but failed to find any robes or knives, nor were there signs of a struggle. Regardless, he was charged with rape and his mother fronted bail costs to enable his release pending court proceedings. Three months after Ivan was released on bail,
结果被前方不远处的警方路障给截停了。被捕后，嫌疑人被确认为 27 岁的伊万·马拉特。他否认强暴玛丽莎，坚称这是双方自愿的行为。两名幸存者被送往戈尔德曼医院接受治疗，尽管医生在玛丽莎身上没有发现任何淤青或伤痕，但格蕾丝的手腕周围有红色印记，这与她曾被捆绑的情况相符。警方搜查了伊万的车，但没有找到任何长袍或刀具，也没有任何打斗迹象。无论如何，他被指控强迫发生性行为，其母亲支付了保释金，以便他在等待法庭审判期间获释。伊万获释三个月后，
he joined his younger brother Michael to conduct a string of armed robberies and home invasions. With the help of two accomplices, the brothers robbed a corner store near Grandville, followed by a small bank in Canley Heights a few days later. They used a stolen vehicle for both crimes but after the second, Ivan was dropped off at his car by his accomplices, where an observant passer-by jotted down his vehicle's license plate number. Police eventually obtained confessions from three of the offenders, including Michael Malat, although Michael would later state his was given under duress after sustaining beatings from interviewing officers. He and Ivan were charged with two counts of armed robbery and
他与弟弟迈克尔联手实施了一系列武装抢劫和入室盗窃。在两名同伙的帮助下，兄弟俩抢劫了格兰维尔附近的一家转角商店，几天后又抢劫了坎利海茨的一起小型银行。他们在两起犯罪中都使用了一辆失窃车辆，但在第二起案件后，伊万被同伙放在了他的车旁，一个细心的路人记下了他车辆的车牌号。警方最终从包括迈克尔·马拉特在内的三名罪犯那里获得了口供，尽管迈克尔后来声称他的口供是在受到审讯警官殴打的胁迫下做出的。他和伊万被控两项武装抢劫罪，
despite the pending rape charge against him, Ivan was again granted bail. Three months later, in October 1971, Ivan met with his lawyer John Marsden outside court to discuss their defence tactic for his armed robbery charges. Marsden admitted to his client that his prospects of beating the charge were, quote, stuff all, and that there was a high chance he would receive a 16-year jail term or longer. Ivan excused himself, explaining he was going to smoke a cigarette, but never returned. His failure to appear at his committal hearing resulted in a warrant being issued for his arrest. Later that same day, police found Ivan's car and a pair of his shoes at the top of the gap, an ocean-side cliff face in eastern Sydney known to be a notorious
尽管身上还背着未决的强奸指控，伊万再次获得保释。三个月后的 1971 年 10 月，伊万在法庭外与他的律师约翰·马斯登会面，讨论他们针对武装抢劫指控的辩护策略。马斯登向他的当事人承认，他打赢这场官司的前景用他的话说就是“微乎其微”，而且他很有可能被判处 16 年或更长的监禁。伊万借口说要去抽根烟便离开了，但再也没有回来。他未能出席听证会，导致警方发出了对他的逮捕令。当天晚些时候，警方在悉尼东部以海景悬崖著称的自杀胜地——“ gap”顶部找到了伊万的车和一双鞋。
suicide spot. Three years later, in 1974, the Malat family's matriarch Margaret was admitted to hospital. During her treatment, a call was placed to New South Wales police informing them that Ivan was present at his mother's bedside. As it turned out, Ivan had staged his suicide at the gap in 1971 before fleeing to New Zealand as travel between the two countries didn't require a passport at the time. He spent a year overseas before returning to Australia where he laid low for the next few years, adopting his brother Bill's identity to avoid detection, as he was one of the Malat sons who hadn't been in any recent trouble with the law. Upon his discovery, Ivan was promptly arrested and this time refused bail, pending trial for both his rape and armed
三年后的 1974 年，马拉特家族的女家长玛格丽特被送入医院。在治疗期间，有人打电话给新南威尔士州警方，告知他们伊万出现在他母亲的床边。事实证明，伊万在 1971 年在 gap 伪造了自杀假象，随后逃往新西兰，因为当时两国之间的旅行不需要护照。他在海外呆了一年后返回澳大利亚，在接下来的几年里一直保持低调，借用他弟弟比尔的身份以躲避侦查，因为比尔是那些最近没有惹上法律麻烦的马拉特兄弟之一。一经发现，伊万当即被捕，这次被拒绝保释，等待强奸和武装抢劫指控的审判。
robbery charges. Ivan's trial for armed robbery began in December 1974. His brother Michael had since received a 16-year sentence for his involvement in the crimes, indicating the outcome didn't look good for Ivan. However, the detectives who originally worked on the case had become the subject of serious corruption allegations, which cast doubt on the evidence they had obtained against the defendants. Furthermore, Michael and the two other accomplices involved in the robberies refused to testify against Ivan and none of the witnesses could provide a positive identification. With all these factors combined, the jury returned a verdict of not guilty. Ivan's rape trial was scheduled for the following day and his lawyer John Marsden
伊万的武装抢劫案审判于 1974 年 12 月开始。他的弟弟迈克尔此前因参与犯罪已被判处 16 年监禁，这表明结果对伊万很不利。然而，最初参与该案侦办的侦探们成为了严重腐败指控的对象，这让人对他们针对被告获取的证据产生怀疑。此外，迈克尔和参与抢劫的另外两名同伙拒绝指证伊万，且没有任何证人能作出积极的辨认。综合所有这些因素，陪审团作出了无罪裁决。伊万的强奸案审判预定在第二天进行，他的律师约翰·马斯登
had advised that a jail sentence seemed highly likely. Yet that evening, Marsden unintentionally stumbled across a situation that he recognized as having the potential to change Ivan's fate. Whilst dining at a gay and lesbian wine bar in Sydney, Marsden spotted Ivan's two survivors, Grace and Marissa, who were holding hands and sharing several intimate moments. Although Marsden was gay himself, the situation presented a decisive opportunity for his client. When Marissa took the stand in court the next day, the defense counsel questioned her whereabouts on the previous night. Marissa explained she had been at home with her parents, allowing John Marsden to catch her in a lie. He pressed her about her presence at the bar
曾建议说判处监禁的可能性极高。然而就在那天晚上，马斯登无意中撞见了一个他认为有可能改变伊万命运的情况。在悉尼的一家同性恋红酒酒吧用餐时，马斯登发现了伊万的两名幸存者格蕾丝和玛丽莎，她们手拉着手，并有几个亲密的举动。尽管马斯登自己也是同性恋，但这为他的当事人提供了一个决定性的契机。第二天玛丽莎走上法庭作证时，辩护律师盘问了她前一天晚上的行踪。玛丽莎解释说她和父母在家，这让约翰·马斯登抓住了她的谎言。他逼问她关于她在悉尼酒吧的情况，
in Sydney, causing Marissa to break down in tears and admit the truth. With the witnesses' sexuality and integrity now under the scrutiny of the conservative jury, Marsden put forth the accusation that the sex acts between Marissa and his client were consensual. The further she was questioned by the defense, the more Marissa began to doubt her original allegations. Marsden asked her, thinking back, you wanted this man to have sex with you, didn't you? To which an emotionally exhausted and uncertain Marissa responded, yes. When later speaking about his actions in court that day in his book, I Am What I Am, John Marsden said, juries in those days were extremely prejudiced against gays and lesbians, and on top of that,
导致玛丽莎崩溃大哭并承认了真相。随着证人的性取向和诚信现在受到保守陪审团的严格审视，马斯登提出了玛丽莎与他的当事人之间的性行为是双方自愿的指控。辩护方对她盘问得越多，玛丽莎就越开始怀疑她最初的指控。马斯登问她：“回想一下，你是想让这个男人跟你发生性关系的，对吧？”对此，情绪精疲力竭且不确定的玛丽莎回答：“是的。”约翰·马斯登后来在他的书《我是我本色》中谈到他在法庭上那天的行为时说：“那时的陪审团对同性恋极具偏见，最重要的是，
we had to put into their minds the possibility that the sex may have indeed been consensual. I'm not proud of my conduct that day, but as a solicitor operating in a courtroom environment at the time, I had no choice but to go down that path. I had to act according to the ethics of the profession. Grace took the stand after her friend, maintaining that she had been forcefully tied up by Ivan and that he had raped Marissa. Despite her testimony, the defense tactic to undermine the survivor's credibility proved advantageous, with the jury returning a verdict of not guilty. The 1971 attack on Grace and Marissa bore many similarities to the crimes committed against the seven backpackers murdered between 1989 and 1992. Investigators believed that,
我们必须让他们脑海中产生一种性行为确实可能是双方自愿的可能性。我为自己那天的行为感到骄傲，但作为当时在法庭环境中运作的律师，我别无选择，只能走那条路。我必须根据职业道德行事。”格蕾丝在她的朋友之后走上证人席，坚称她曾被伊万强行捆绑，且他强暴了玛丽莎。尽管有她的证词，但辩护方旨在削弱幸存者可信度的策略被证明是奏效的，陪审团最终作出了无罪裁决。1971 年对格蕾丝和玛丽莎的袭击与 1989 年至 1992 年间对七名背包客实施谋杀的罪行有许多相似之处。调查人员认为，
just like Grace and Marissa, the young hitchhikers were offered a lift by a man who took them along the Hume Highway towards Belangelo before threatening them with a weapon and restraining them with ropes. The now 49-year-old Ivan Malat also bore a striking resemblance to the man identified as Bill, who had attempted to abduct English backpacker Paul Unions in early 1990. Ivan intermittently sported a bushy horseshoe-style mustache, was stocky, and had a Yugoslavian father. Ivan was also known to go by his brother's name, Bill, when hesitant to use his own. At the time of Paul Unions' attack, Ivan was the owner of a Silver Nissan Patrol four-wheel drive, the same vehicle used by Paul's assailant.
就像格蕾丝和玛丽莎一样，年轻的搭车客被一个男人搭救，并沿着休姆高速公路将他们带到贝兰格洛，随后用武器威胁他们并用绳子捆绑他们。现年 49 岁的伊万·马拉特也与那个被辨认为比尔的男人惊人地相似，后者曾在 1990 年初试图绑架英国背包客保罗·尤宁斯。伊万断断续续地留着浓密的马蹄形胡须，身材魁梧，父亲是南斯拉夫。当不愿使用自己的名字时，伊万也以他弟弟比尔的名字示人。在保罗·尤宁斯遇袭期间，伊万是一辆银色日产途乐四驱车的主人，这正是保罗的袭击者所驾驶的同一辆车。
Additionally, Paul's attacker stated he worked for the Roads and Traffic Authority in Liverpool, which Ivan did at the time. Further inquiries revealed Ivan was not at work on January 25, 1990, the day of Paul Unions' failed abduction. Likewise, he was confirmed to have been on leave on the dates all seven Belangelo murder victims went missing. Ivan claimed to work colleagues that he had been in Queensland throughout early to mid-January 1991. Yet, his Nissan Patrol was photographed by a red light camera in Sydney at midnight on the 16th, proving he was back home when Simone Schmidl disappeared only days later. Just over a week after Gabor, Noigabella and Anja Habshe disappeared, Ivan approached his next-door neighbour,
此外，保罗的袭击者声称自己在利物浦的道路和交通管理局工作，伊万当时也确实在那里工作。进一步的调查显示，1990 年 1 月 25 日（即保罗·尤宁斯遇袭未遂当天），伊万并没有去上班。同样，经证实，所有七名贝兰格洛谋杀案受害者失踪的日期他都在休假。伊万向同事声称自己在整个 1991 年 1 月上旬到中旬期间都呆在昆士兰州。然而，他的日产途乐在 16 日午夜被悉尼的一台红灯照相机拍到，这证明西蒙妮·施米德尔失踪几天后他已经回到了家中。就在加博尔、诺伊加贝拉和安雅·哈普谢失踪一周多后，伊万找到他的邻居——
a former mechanic and panel-beater, asking if he could fix a hole in his Nissan Patrol. When the neighbour inspected the damage, he immediately recognised it as a bullet hole. Ivan explained he was on a hunting trip when his gun discharged from the driver's seat and impacted the front passenger side door. The hole was patched and re-sprayed, with the fastidious Ivan recording the repair job in his vehicle's manual. Upon his return to work, Ivan pointed out the repair job to his co-workers, which was evident given that the paint used to cover the hole was not an exact match to the car's original colour. Ivan later sold the Nissan and replaced it with another four-wheel drive,
一位前机械师兼钣金工，问他能不能修补他的日产途乐上的一个洞。当邻居检查损伤时，他立刻认出那是一个弹孔。伊万解释说，他在一次打猎时枪在驾驶座上走火，击中了前乘客侧车门。这个洞被补好并重新喷了漆，严谨的伊万还将这次维修工作记录在了车辆手册中。重返工作岗位后，伊万向同事们指出了维修处，这很明显，因为用于遮盖弹孔的漆与汽车原本的颜色并不完全匹配。伊万后来卖掉了这辆日产汽车，换成了另一辆四驱车，
a red-holden Jackaroo, alternating between driving this vehicle and his beloved Harley-Davidson motorcycle. After confirming Ivan Malat was unaccounted for when all Belangelo victims went missing, he became a prime suspect for their murders. However, Task Force air investigators still had insufficient grounds to justify an application to have a phone intercept door-listening device installed in Ivan's home or to request a search warrant. On February 26, 1994, Ivan was placed under police surveillance as investigators watched the home he shared with his sister Shirley on Cinnabar Street in Eaglevale, as well as his work site in southwestern Sydney. Cinnabar Street residents noticed the irregular
一辆红色的霍顿杰卡鲁，在这辆车和他钟爱的哈雷戴维森摩托车之间交替驾驶。在确认伊万·马拉特在所有贝兰格洛受害者失踪期间都不在场后，他成了他们遇害的主要嫌疑人。然而，空中特遣队调查人员仍然没有足够的理由来证明申请在伊万家中安装电话窃听器或监听设备，或是申请搜查令的合理性。1994 年 2 月 26 日，伊万被置于警方监控之下，调查人员监视了他与姐姐雪莉合住在伊格尔维尔辰砂街的住所，以及他在悉尼西南部的工地。辰砂街的居民注意到社区里出现了异常
activity in the neighbourhood, which began with the plumbing van parked on the street corner, followed by the ongoing appearance of an electricity van. A hold on Commodore was also seen driving around the area on numerous occasions, prompting concerned locals to fear that a gang was scoping out their neighbourhood to plan an elaborate robbery. One neighbour called police to report the suspicious vehicles and was advised that they were part of a major operation, which quickly became the talk of Eaglevale. During the early days of the surveillance operation on Ivan Malat, Superintendent Small was interviewed about the Balingelo serial killer case for the ABC's current affairs program Four
活动，先是一辆水管工货车停在街角，接着是一辆电力公司的货车频繁出现。一辆霍顿海军准将车也被多次看到在这一地区行驶，这促使担忧的当地人担心有一个帮派正在踩点他们的社区以图策划一场精心谋划的抢劫。一名邻居打电话给警方报告这些可疑车辆，并被告知它们是一项重大行动的一部分，这很快成了伊格尔维尔街谈巷议的话题。在对伊万·马拉特进行监控行动的早期，斯莫尔总警司就巴兰格洛连环杀人案接受了澳大利亚广播公司（ABC）时事节目《四角》的采访。
Corners. The interview took place in Small's office, where he firmly denied that there were any suspects in the killings. Unbeknownst to the superintendent, the footage captured a whiteboard positioned behind him, which displayed the words, air slash Malat. When the program aired on March 4, 1994, an astute viewer noticed this detail and contacted both the ABC and Task Force air detectives to complain. The viewer was Alex Malat, who was unaware his younger brother was being viewed as a suspect for the murders. Alex was concerned the whiteboard featured his surname due to the previous statements he had provided to police regarding the two gagged women he witnessed being driven into Balingelo. Four Corners agreed to pixelate the Malat name
采访在斯莫尔的办公室进行，他在采访中坚决否认杀戮事件有任何嫌疑人。总警司并不知道，镜头拍到他身后摆着一块白板，上面写着“空中斜线马拉特”。当节目于 1994 年 3 月 4 日播出时，一个精明的观众注意到了这个细节，并联系了澳大利亚广播公司和空中特遣队侦探进行投诉。这名观众是亚历克斯·马拉特，他并不知道他的弟弟被当作谋杀案嫌疑人看待。亚历克斯担心白板上会出现他的姓氏，因为他之前曾向警方提供过关于他目击两名被堵嘴的女子被开车运往巴兰格洛的陈述。《四角》同意在该剧集的重播中
during repeats of the episode and nothing further came of it. Task Force air had narrowly avoided a close call that could have jeopardised their entire operation. As the surveillance continued into mid-March, investigators grew increasingly concerned that their suspect may be onto them. Inquiries by one detective hadn't been as discreet as directed, and Ivan had been informed by colleagues and associates that police were investigating him in relation to the Balingelo murders. Ivan appeared to be unfazed and would grin at the news, saying he had nothing to worry about. In one instance, Ivan was driving with a co-worker who observed a car that appeared to be following them. Ivan calmly stated, that's the coppers, they're watching me.
将马拉特这个名字进行像素化处理，此事便无后续。空中特遣队险险避过了一场可能危及其整个行动的危机。随着监控持续到 3 月中旬，调查人员越来越担心他们的嫌疑人可能已经察觉到他们了。一名侦探的调查不像指示的那样谨慎，伊万已被同事和同伙告知警方正在就巴兰格洛谋杀案调查他。伊万对此似乎并不在意，听到消息时还咧嘴笑笑，说自己没什么好担心的。有一次，伊万和一位同事开车时，同事发现有一辆车似乎在跟着他们。伊万镇定地说：“那是条子，他们在盯着我。”
Although the surveillance operation failed to uncover anything incriminating, it was noted that Ivan suddenly started paying unannounced visits to people he hadn't seen in years, including old neighbours and work colleagues. Investigators believed he may have been digging around to see just how far their inquiries had progressed. Concerned that the surveillance might compel their suspect to dispose of evidence, in early April, Superintendent Clive Small ordered a temporary halt on the operation while investigators assessed the risk. 18 days later, the surveillance was deemed safe to continue. As the operation recommenced, police were anxious to uncover some hard evidence to link
尽管监控行动未能发现任何能定罪的东西，但人们注意到伊万突然开始不请自来地拜访那些他多年未见的人，包括老邻居和同事。调查人员认为他可能在四处打探，想看看他们的调查到底进展到了什么地步。出于担心监控可能会迫使嫌疑人销毁证据，克莱夫·斯莫尔总警司在 4 月初下令暂时中止行动，同时调查人员评估风险。18 天后，经评估监控可以安全继续。随着行动重新开始，警方急切地想要发现一些确凿的证据，把
Ivan Malat to the Balingelo murders. They sought assistance from the person that could most likely help identify their suspect, Paul Onions. Paul arrived in Sydney from England on May 2, 1994, where he agreed to re-enact the events from four years earlier. Paul took detectives from the Liverpool train station to Lombardo's news agency in Kassoula, where he had accepted a ride from the man who introduced himself as Bill. Paul then drove with detectives along the Hume Highway, where he pointed out the area that his violent confrontation with Bill occurred. A location just 900 metres north of the Balingelo forest entrance. Afterwards, Paul was shown a video containing the photographs of 13 different males and was advised to point out any that he recognized
伊万·马拉特和巴兰格洛谋杀案联系起来。他们向最有可能帮助辨认嫌疑人的人——保罗·尤宁斯——寻求协助。保罗于 1994 年 5 月 2 日从英国抵达悉尼，并同意重现四年前的事件。保罗带着侦探们从利物浦火车站来到卡苏拉的隆巴多报社，他正是在那里接受了一个自称叫比尔的男人的搭车。随后，保罗和侦探们沿着休姆高速公路开车，指出了他与比尔发生暴力对抗的区域。那个地点距离巴兰格洛森林入口仅 900 米以北。此后，保罗观看了一段包含 13 名不同男性的照片的视频，并被告知指出任何他认出的
as the man who assaulted him in 1990. The video played through in full, after which Paul requested the view it again. After the second viewing, he asked to have another look at images 4 and 7. When number 4 came up, Paul said, that's him. Photograph number 4 was of Ivan Malat. Task Force Air now had enough evidence against Ivan Malat to charge him with the attempted abduction and armed robbery of Paul Onions. This permitted them to obtain a listening device on the telephone line connected to Ivan's Eaglevale property. They considered installing additional listening devices inside the house, but a complex electronic security system which
在 1990 年袭击过他的男人。视频完整播放完毕后，保罗要求再看一遍。看完第二遍后，他要求再看一眼第 4 号和第 7 号图像。当第 4 号出现时，保罗说：“就是他。”第 4 号照片正是伊万·马拉特。空中特遣队现在掌握了足够的证据来指控伊万·马拉特涉嫌绑架未遂和武装抢劫保罗·尤宁斯。这使得他们得以在连接伊万的伊格尔维尔房产的电话线上安装监听设备。他们曾考虑在屋里安装额外的监听设备，但有一个复杂的电子安全系统，
Ivan activated every time he left home was near impossible to bypass without detection. Despite Paul Onions positively identifying Ivan as the man who attacked him near Balingelo, investigators still hadn't obtained any concrete evidence that proved Ivan's involvement in the murders of James Gibson, Deborah Everest, Simone Schmidel, Gabor Neugebauer, Anya Habsheed, Joanne Walters or Caroline Clark. As criminal profilers were certain the Balingelo serial killer would have retained some of his victims' belongings as morbid trophies, the Task Force considered conducting a raid of Ivan's home. Yet, it was a huge risk. If they proceeded and found nothing, their cover would be well and truly blown. But, if they managed to find a single item to link
伊万每次离家时都会将其激活，几乎不可能在不被发现的情况下绕过它。尽管保罗·尤宁斯已明确指认伊万就是那个在巴兰格洛附近袭击他的人，但调查人员仍未获得任何确凿证据来证明伊万参与了詹姆斯·吉布森、黛博拉·埃弗雷斯特、西蒙妮·施米德尔、加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔、安雅·哈普谢、琼妮·沃尔特斯或卡罗琳·克拉克的谋杀案。由于犯罪侧写师确信巴兰格洛连环杀手会保留一些受害者的财物作为病态战利品，特遣队考虑对伊万的家进行突袭。然而，这是一个巨大的风险。如果他们行动了却一无所获，他们的卧底身份就会彻底暴露。但是，如果他们设法找到了一件能将
Ivan to the crimes, like one of the murder weapons or a backpack, sleeping bag or passport belongings to one of the seven victims, they could make their case. After weighing up the pros and cons, Task Force Air decided to go through with the raid. The surveillance team were ordered to continue to keep a close eye on Ivan in the days leading up to the event, in case he attempted to dispose of any evidence. The day before the scheduled raid on Ivan Malat's home, two Task Force Air detectives paid a visit to the Southern Highlands town of Bargo to question Ivan's younger brother Bill and his wife Caroline, hoping their visit might generate some chatter on Ivan's phone line.
伊万与罪行联系起来的物品，比如其中一把凶器、一个背包、睡袋或属于七名受害者之一的护照，他们就能破案了。权衡利弊后，空中特遣队决定实施突袭。在事件发生前的几天里，监控团队奉命继续密切监视伊万，以防他企图销毁任何证据。在对伊万·马拉特家计划突袭的前一天，两名空中特遣队侦探造访了南部高地小镇巴戈，盘问伊万的弟弟比尔和他的妻子卡罗琳，希望他们的造访能在伊万的电话线上引发一些闲聊。
The detectives were greeted by the couple's daughter, Deborah, who was at the house with her infant son Matthew, while her parents holidayed in the South Coast town of Lake Tabari. The detectives advised the Deborah they wanted to speak to Bill about Ivan's habit of registering vehicles using his name. When Deborah later phoned her father to inform him of the visit, he instructed her to pass the information on to Ivan. Deborah spoke to her uncle that night, but Ivan brushed off her concerns, instead inquiring about his baby nephew, stating, Don't worry about it. Now, how's little Matthew? That same day, detectives traveled down to Lake Tabari to question Bill in person, explaining
侦探们受到了这对夫妇的女儿黛博拉的接待，她当时正和婴儿儿子马修在家，而她的父母则在南海岸小镇塔巴里湖度假。侦探们告知黛博拉，他们想就伊万用他的名字登记车辆的习惯跟比尔谈谈。黛博拉后来打电话给父亲告知这次造访时，他指示她把消息转达给伊万。黛博拉当晚和她的叔叔通了电话，但伊万对她的担忧不以为意，反而打听起他的小侄子，并说道：“别担心。现在，小马修怎么样？”同一天，侦探们驱车前往塔巴里湖亲自盘问比尔，解释
their inquiries were in relation to an armed robbery. As to why Ivan registered vehicles under his name, Bill stated it was to make use of his rural address, as registration and insurance were cheaper in his area. Bill later phoned his brother, but once again, Ivan expressed no worry that police were actively investigating him. Detectives listening in on the calls pondered whether Ivan's calm reaction was a cover as he suspected his phone calls were being monitored. The surveillance team maintained watch of Ivan the entire day, observing that at 1.27 p.m. he traveled to the town of Kasula to visit Lombardo's news agency, the very place he once offered a ride to the young foreign traveler, Paul Onions.
他们的调查与一起武装抢劫有关。至于为什么伊万以他的名字登记车辆，比尔称那是为了利用他的乡村地址，因为他那里的注册和保险更便宜。比尔后来给他的弟弟打了电话，但伊万再次表现出对警方正在积极调查他毫不担心。监听通话的侦探们琢磨着，伊万冷静的反应是否只是在掩饰，因为他怀疑自己的电话正在被监控。监控团队一整天都在监视伊万，观察到下午 1点 27 分他前往卡苏拉小镇拜访隆巴多报社，也就是他曾经向年轻的外国旅行者保罗·尤宁斯提供搭车的地方。
Elsewhere that same day, the day before the raid was scheduled at Ivan's house. Other detectives traveled to Queensland to visit Ivan's brother, Alex, who had since relocated interstate from his southern Highlands home. The timing of his move was of interest to investigators, as it occurred shortly after Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark's remains were discovered in Balingalo. After he and his wife Joanne welcomed detectives inside, Alex once again maintained his story about witnessing two restrained women being driven into Balingalo in 1992, scrupulously sticking by his original statement. Since the spotlight had been cast on Ivan, investigators considered the possibility that
同一天稍早，即突袭伊万家计划的前一天。其他侦探前往昆士兰拜访了伊万的弟弟亚历克斯，他此前已经从南部高地的家中搬到了州际。他搬家的时机引起了调查人员的兴趣，因为这发生在琼妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克的遗体在巴兰格洛被发现后不久。他和妻子琼妮将侦探们迎进屋后，亚历克斯再次坚持了他在 1992 年目击两名被捆绑的女子被开车运往巴兰格洛的说辞，一丝不苟地坚持他最初的陈述。自从聚光灯打在伊万身上后，调查人员便考虑了这样一种可能性：
Alex knew his brother was involved with the murders and made up the bizarre sighting as a way to tip police off without blatantly coming forward and betraying his younger sibling. Alex admitted to owning ammunition and presented his large supplier, which included several .22 caliber Winchester brand winner model bullets, the exact same type recovered from Caroline Clark and Gabor Neugebauer's crime scenes. Alex made no comment about the potentially incriminating ammunition. Detectives spoke with Joanne and Alex further. During their conversation, Joanne suddenly made an unprompted comment about serial killers and how they often liked
亚历克斯知道他的弟弟卷入了谋杀案，并编造了那个离奇的目击事件，以此作为向警方通风报信的一种方式，而又不用公然站出来背叛他年幼的弟弟。亚历克斯承认自己拥有弹药并展示了他的大宗弹药库，其中包括几颗 .22 口径温彻斯特牌赢家型号子弹，这与从卡罗琳·克拉克和加博尔·诺伊盖鲍尔的犯罪现场回收的完全是同一类型。亚历克斯没有对这些可能具有 incriminating（定罪作用的）弹药发表任何评论。侦探们与琼妮和亚历克斯进一步交谈。谈话中，琼妮突然无缘无故地评论起连环杀手以及他们如何常常喜欢
to keep souvenirs from their victims, stating, quote, you know, like backpacks. The stunned detectives remained stone faced as they asked Joanne if she owned any backpacks. Joanne nodded and presented a blue Salewa brand pack adorned with a lilac pattern. The detectives recognized it immediately. It was identical to the one carried by Simone Schmiddle. Joanne opened up the top flap and pointed out a pair of initials that were imprinted underneath. I am. When asked where she got the backpack from, Joanne replied. Ivan gave it to me. In the early hours of Sunday, May 22, 1994, Superintendent Small briefed 50 police officers in preparation for their deployment to Eaglevale. Quote,
保留受害者的纪念品，并引用原话称，你知道的，比如背包。震惊的侦探们面无表情地问乔安妮她是否有背包。乔安妮点点头，拿出一个饰有丁香花图案的蓝色沙乐华牌背包。侦探们一眼就认出来了。它与西蒙娜·施米德勒背的那个一模一样。乔安妮打开顶盖，指着印在底部的两个首字母。我。当被问及背包是从哪里来时，乔安妮回答说。伊万给我的。1994年5月22日星期日清晨，小警司向50名警察做简报，为他们部署到伊格尔维尔做准备。引用，
We're here to arrest Ivan Malat over the attempted abduction and attempt to shoot poor onions. Malat is considered a violent and dangerous person. He is believed to be well armed. We don't know what to expect and are not taking any chances. Six squad cars blocked off Cinnabar Street at both ends, while tactical police secured the inner perimeter of Ivan's property, where their suspect and his girlfriend, Chalinda, were sleeping inside. By 6.36am, the house was surrounded. Police negotiator Detective Wayne Gordon placed a phone call to the home and a groggy Ivan Malat picked up, saying, Hello. To be continued next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们来这里是为了逮捕因企图绑架和试图枪击可怜的洋葱而犯案的伊万·马拉特。马拉特被认为是一个暴力而危险的人。据信他武装精良。我们不知道会发生什么，不会抱任何侥幸心理。六辆警车封锁了辰砂街的两端，而战术警察则守住了伊万住所的内围，嫌疑人他的女友查林达当时正在里面睡觉。到早上6点36分，房子已被包围。警方谈判专家韦恩·戈登侦探拨通了家里的电话，睡眼惺忪的伊万·马拉特接了电话，说道：“喂。下周未完待续。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。